is it like Jennifer Lawrence because
then you won't like Jennifer Lawrence
pee all over your couch and then lick
her wet pants I mean Jennifer Lawrence
thing about lesbian porn is most of it
is not made for lesbians it makes it
look like we have completely all those
bags so we've got our rubric right here
first thing on the rubric is storyline
level of foreplay turns on this nail
fakeness is that really that big of a
deal
and then believability do you want to
click the link let's watch some lesbian
porn
why not horny teen lesbian seduced by
sisters I hope it's not incest she's not
gonna join them is she that's her sister
what are they interested in them like
rice-a-roni and now they're do you see
what they're doing with their tongues
and now they're naked magically oh she's
naked
how did when do those Batgirl just look
straight into the camera now that
lesbian teens kinky pissing video okay
okay she literally looks like she's
getting her medical exam
what's going on in there the classic
straight girl is like wax on wax off
she's taking her fists of jeans and
didn't squeezing their XSP who are they
where are they from do they know each
other are they related are they friends
do they work together are they strangers
did she just walk into her house was she
gonna break in was she gonna steal
something now they're having sex why did
she pee on her busty brunette tries hard
to seduce her straight to blonde
roommates punish my little [ __ ] ass is
what she says this is definitely like
porn for mommy
yeah she's RAM hair right now by the way
the harness for the strap-on is
bedazzled okay now there's 69
she's literally she was like oh and now
we have scissoring all right scissoring
has arrived they have this double-ended
dildo and this one girl she's like dude
throwing it that thing is so large it's
huge
overall I said not real lesbians it just
makes me very sad that people are
watching these videos like thinking that
this is what sex is like between two
women when clearly it's I don't know
much more than that there's lack of like
communication and things that I feel
like go into it and I feel like people
just get the wrong idea it's not real
it's not honest it's not for the
audience that it is apparently for it's
just it's sucks no no this is really
please based on a survey that any woman
gay straight whatever would find any of
that remotely pleasurable
[Music]